You don't know what's possible and
you're not as much as you could be.
And so God only knows what you could,
what you could do and have and give
if you sacrificed everything to it.
And that's the reason that Abraham
is constantly making sacrifices.
It's archaic,
right?
He's burning up like baby lambs,
but like,
well,
they're alive.
You know,
that's something and they're valuable.
And that's something it's,
you have to admit,
even if you think about
it as a modern person,
that the act of sacrificing something
might have some dramatic compulsion to it.
You know,
to go out into a flock and to take
something that's newborn and to cut its
throat into bleed it into burn.
It might be a way of
indicating to yourself that
you're actually serious about
something.
And it isn't so obvious that we have
rituals of seriousness like that now.
And so it's not so obvious that we're
actually serious about anything.
And so maybe that's not such a good thing.
And so maybe we shouldn't be thinking
that these people were so archaic and
primitive and superstitious.
It's possible that they knew
something that we don't.
And certainly in the Abrahamic stories,
one of the things that maintains
Abraham's covenant with God is continually
willingness to sacrifice it.
It's so that sacrificial issue is so
important because you are not committed to
something unless you're
willing to sacrifice for it.
Commitment and sacrifice are
the same thing and I think it's,
it borders on miraculous that
those concepts are embedded
into this narrative at
the level of dramatic action.
You know,
instead of abstract explanation,
people are acting this out and the,
and the fundamental conception is
so profound that it's really quite,
it's quite are inspiring.
It's breathtaking really.
When you understand what message
is trying to be conveyed,
you have to make sacrifices and
what do you have to sacrifice?
You have to sacrifice that which is most
valuable to you currently that stopping
you and God only knows what that is.
It's certainly the worst of you.
It's certainly that and god only knows
to what degree you're in love with the
worst of you so
well,
so you moved from the unbearable
present to the ideal future and,
and you can't help that.
You have to live in a structure like that,
that's your house.
That's another way of thinking about it.
And if you want to get
your house in order,
and if you want it to be a place
that you can live properly,
then you have to plan the future.
That is perfect.
And then I think,
well,
what does that mean?
It means it's good for you.
Right?
And one of the things that I,
I'm,
I do all the time with my clinical and
consulting clients is try to figure out
what would be good for them.
But we do more than that.
We try to think,
okay,
well what,
how can we set this up so
it's really good for you?
And that all of the side consequences of
that are things that are good for other
people.
And so because people are often also
timid about trying to get something that's
good for themselves because they feel
that it's selfish or that they don't
deserve it.
So we set it up so that,
well look,
we're going to set it up so that it's
plainly obvious that this will not harm
the structure of the universe.
For you to have what you need and to do
it in a way that's of benefit to other
people.
There's no downside to that.
And so it's okay.
It's okay if you reach out and take that.
And one of the things that's
interesting about the biblical stories,
Abrahamic stories as well,
is that God doesn't really seem to be
opposed to this success of the people that
he's chosen.
You know,
what happens to them as,
as they progress through their journey,
as they get larger flocks and they,
they get more authority and they,
they get,
they get more,
they get life more abundant.
That's what happens.
It's God isn't,
doesn't seem to be a miser
in the old testament.
It's like if you put
in the effort and you,
and you accept the covenant
and you make the sacrifices,
then you get to be successful and maybe
successful beyond your wildest dreams.
And that that's actually
seems to be okay with God.
And that's pretty cool
given that you know,
that that general notion of Old Testament
God is that all he's doing is casting
out curses and death,
you know,
wherever he happens to wander.
And I mean there's certainly
no shortage of that,
but,
but again,
it seems to be that that's very good
news and that you also don't have to be
perfect in order for to have that happen.
And then the other thing,
this is the issue about
going into the unknown.
It's like,
well,
if you leave your country and your kin
and your father's house and you go out
into a land that your
intuition guides you to,
you're going to undergo these
radical transformations.
This is a sacrificial
transformation too because you're,
you're moving forthrightly
and voluntarily into chaos,
right?
And that's the same as the dragon fight.
That's the hero of the story.
And what will happen there is
that you will transform yourself.
And so the call to an ideal is also
the call to a sequence of deaths and
rebirths that move you closer
and closer to the ideal.
And that's what,
that's what God is calling Abraham to do.
In the first sentence of this story.